alors si lille donc moi je vais
commencer cette chronique avec deux
éléments perturbateurs puisqu'on a fait
il y a deux chroniqueurs qui gangrènent
votre équipe n'a pas que deux a dit
qu'on n'aura pas les deux premiers déjà
on essaie janvier qui dit da kg mais
kelly et se chamaillent beaucoup mais il
ne travaille pas ça je le savais à peu
les dires clément et ne foutent rien je
veux dire c'est les deux seules
personnes qui mettent leur réveil à 17
heures
regardez c'est le retour d'un gars une
kelly
[Musique]
des avions gros dommages
je ne veux pas
quand il
[Applaudissements]
paul kelly la chronique aux préféré
notre île étant cemac robin que ce
préfet rêvait tous les temps loin de là
mais rooney italie sa casquette
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
j'ai une excellente mise
[Applaudissements]
savoir où les matins dans le rectum
c'est pour l'environnement savez vous si
vous avez très peu de l'environnement y
avait une forêt en match et vous vous
allez avoir le temps de cueillir des
champignons que le trop chaude au chili
oui ce soir après touche pas à mon poste
il ya une autre grande émission c'est
évidemment ce soir d'ailleurs en direct
évidemment alors on sait que pour les
deux émissions c'est le même animateur
mais est ce que c'est vraiment la même
personne qui anime mais c'est la même
personne jallet tu arrives tu m'as pas
toujours vous êtes complètement fou
cyril et vous savez quoi
j'adore ça regarde ce qui lui procure
[Musique]
samedi après midi en plein paris un
homme est interpellé plaqué au sol par
plusieurs policiers
g berne a sondé coincé c'est comme ça je
suis plus du tout les aînés il n'a pas
toujours cher qu'un témoin d'un terrible
malaise dans la profession depuis
plusieurs affaires qui sont venus
entacher les trois pas mal de gens qui
disent que jean-michel peau du cul les
cherry en fait ton assez pour lutter
contre la drogue en france
et selon vous chez vous en direct on me
pose la question
la police est-elle trop violente il ya
sortant du gouvernement kabyle se
canaliser les gouvernements passent mais
l'histoire semble se répéter
[Applaudissements]
d'autant qu'au delà de leur dû
j'ai beau me détendre l'atmosphère vous
me le dites un messie mais vous êtes un
showman c'est ça qu'on aime ciel oui on
dirait que j'ai dit qu'aux états unis
s'élèvent cette semaine vous m'avez fait
l'honneur la chance d'être autour de
vous avez été excellente
c'est gentil merci couple sasha bravo
merci beaucoup c'est vrai il est très
bien connu et donc la non mais c'est
dingue et s'affale est-ce que et non
c'est pas là relève c'est non non non et
même chaque attaque et la voilà mais du
coup j'ai profité de cette chance pour
faire quoi
et bien pour remplir mon rôle d'un dyke
je vois tout je sais d'où je dénonce
tout qu'est-ce que j'ai fait un bac j'ai
sorti mon petit téléphone au pied et
puis celle à l'horloge comme ça qu'est
ce que j'ai fait j'ai fait alors venez
comment ça marche cette semaine et tout
mais en même temps je fais mais on ne
sera pas dans votre spectacle
[Rires]
et du coup le cirill josé ramener plein
de dos mais l'étau qui va suivre
vous avez bernard montiel le sadique à
vous avez sonné malville et isabelle à
ça de ce péché l'annoncé d'amitié
attention il est marié et luigi vous
avez luigi qu'à tirer les vers du nez
non à ben jama sur jean mi vous allez
découvrir plein de choses c'est une
nouvelle séquence en exclusivité pour tp
mpc les coulisses des loges regard des
faits olala casino où j'étais assise à
même toit mais parmi ma vie aux bonnes
moeurs isabelle j'appuie message pas à
pas et on dit un truc c'est quoi je ne
sais pas non à berlin
jean-louis sahara occidental j'arrive
qualys réseau sur pie x les voulait plus
avoir et pas dans le bon sens sur son
âge ses blagues s'étaient tous lieux
portait ses cheveux message aura vu et
mieux profiler les aimer choisir si on
avait demandé autant dans les précisions
je passe sur la question quatre anciens
dirigeants de l'ue et rapide où vous
conservez vous oui vous avez eu un
partenariat avec une marque pour les
pulls non pourquoi vous avez acheté le
même pull à djassem répète tout est cool
les acheter bah oui absolument
chez chez zadig oui sans voltaire
symbole je sais il paraît que vous êtes
allez y vous avez dépensé beaucoup
d'argent ce qui nous a dit que voulez
vous c'est un musée de la prod pour
mamie pour l'émission jeu sans appel
même budget
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
parmi ces propos est ce que vous trouvez
beau jean-michel je me défends ta mère
est ce que vous sentez pas un peu
résistible penser que toutes les femmes
vous sont dus série cette semaine hors
serait dit on dit pour ce ver romane
serda a été une très belle femme c'est
que toutes les femmes sont dues bah non
c'est moi je prévois romane serda
tressaillez de la pêcherie croit qu'il
peut essayer et chaud tout le monde mais
en fait ça marche pas à tous les coups
regardez voire avant
[Musique]
ça fait 10 c
c'est là
regardez c'est de capter regard
[Musique]
merci c'est gentil
tu m'as l'air bien
[Musique]
romane vous avez déjà leur coup de
foudre
ouais quoi c'est vraiment au genre vous
êtes dit ouais c'est ça y est c
merde dans les yeux
décaillet du coeur mais ça veut dire
quand on fait ça
[Musique]
mais en plus rien à voir mais roma de la
même part gardiens sont dégueulasses et
lass lass et a doublé la mise au ban du
week end j c'est grave bah c'est
incroyable s'est fait plaisir et
histoire non mais c'est vrai regardez sa
valise à regarder eux s'ils ont des
enfants ils vont naître il aura des
raisons déjà cinq ans à l'enfant il
venait d'y mettre direct à la retraite
et il va moi rigoler dans un instant
la barre mais ça que j'étais ce quinté
c'est vrai d'accord maintenant que votre
apparence capillaire votre épiderme
votre éclats on passe avant les médias
si c'est pas faux pas dans le nouveau
coiffeur visagiste de ppp oui les
équipes d'adp h2o productions la boîte
de prod et ben vous à la maison regarder
bien le magnéto qui va suivre
cyril a reçu un nouveau joujou pour sa
pause cette semaine et il ne peut plus
s'en lasser c'est leur tour s'en passer
cette fois ci j'ai dit quoi sur la
sellette ne peut plus s'en passer des
français c'est le retour de ses forces à
la danse
la relève et sauna facial est une
méthode couramment samantha who
comment ça va les chéris aujourd'hui sur
le sur le plateau télé vous avez de quoi
faire sa soeur chaud mais sur ce sens où
tu vois pas comment tu vois pas comment
mes pores sont craindre à dilater et
vous respectez pas vos portes et c'est
quoi le processus en fait alors le
processus est très simple ça c'est ce
qu'on appelle un sauna facial
c'est pour ouvrir les pores les et
pluton port est ouvert plus tabou est
prête à accueillir des nutritionnistes
et mon visage là quand je suis arrivée
qui était terne regardez-la déjà dans
mon village est en train de s'illuminer
j'ai un pedigree la flégère bing à
l'abricot à la maison arrête un peu tu
vas manière fait une très mauvaise
réputation au milieu l'esthétique
pourquoi parce que j'ai enquêté on m'a
dit tu te présenter au rendez vous on y
puiser quelques peeling quelques hydras
faciale
ouais et qui revenait pas à fait
certaine sarah et écoute je vais te dire
la vérité on m'a jamais parlé comme ça
ça te dérange il travaille un petit peu
sur l'émission donc tu veux dire durant
ce temps la priorité
[Applaudissements]
un facial et je regardais kajima - il
fait des saunas faciaux parce qu'il a
une peau d'illuminer le penalty de
choses j'ai une petite dernière une
petit dernier oui c'est personnel je me
suis l'ami savez cyril je voulais dit
alors on va nicolas et payet on n'a pas
à la page en fait là ses projets avec
plaisir profitant là bas voilà bah je
vais faire des cours à l'essai et
n'oublie pas oui tu seras la boue avec
robert dubuc chéri
[Applaudissements]